how do we solve problems involving
massive police using Newton's laws as a
simple example let's look at this
problem consisting of a block of mass M
one hanging from a massive pulley that
has a moment of inertia I and radius R
we'll find the acceleration of the block
a one and the angular acceleration of
the massive pulley alpha it is critical
to remember that the first step in
solving these problems is to define the
positive x and y directions and the
positive direction of rotation in
two-dimensional problems you're free to
define any direction to be positive here
we'll set our positive x and positive Y
like this
once we pick x and y the direction of
the positive rotation is now also
defined by the right hand rule you'll
see shortly that defining positive
directions at the beginning will save
you from a negative sign nightmare later
on now let's write down Newton's laws
for the different parts of the system
first for the block we will write down
the linear version of Newton's second
law for the sum of forces we have
gravity pointing down and tension
pointing up according to the convention
we just defined t 1 is positive and M 1
G is negative notice that since the
block is accelerating T 1 minus m1g is
not zero but is equal to m1a 1 notice
that here we've set the signs for
tension and weight but we don't yet know
which way the block is accelerating so
we just start by writing m1 a1 and if in
the end we get that a1 is negative we'll
know that it's actually accelerating in
the negative direction now let's look at
the pulley Newton's second law in its
rotational form is tau is equal to I
alpha for a normal pulley the string is
always tangential to the side of the
pulley so R and F are perpendicular so
that means the torque is just T 1 times
R what's the sign of this term well
according to the positive direction that
we defined this torque is positive
again we'll leave the sign of the il fuh
term to be positive and alpha will turn
out to be either positive or negative
finally we need to connect these two
equations because the block is connected
to the pulley using an ideal taut and
extensible rope a 1 is going to be
related to alpha we just need to figure
out exactly how they're related in other
words we need to write down the
constraint condition let's say that the
block hypothetically is moving upwards
in this case what's happening to the
pulley it must be spinning clockwise to
pull the rope up as the block goes in so
it has a clockwise angular velocity
which according to our convention is
negative in fact if the pulley rotates a
full turn in the clockwise negative
direction the angle changes by negative
2 pi and 2 pi times R of the rope will
be pulled up so we can write that Delta
Y is equal to negative R Delta Theta or
taking some derivatives a1 is equal to
negative R times alpha after setting the
sign conventions writing Newton's laws
for different parts of the system and
then writing down the constraint
condition we have three equations and
three unknowns for which we can now
solve